we know that ashara dayne danced with
net we know that she was a Serb our
stand calls a dishonor by a stark at
Harrenhal and we know that Asher gave a
birth to a child that child is Jon Snow
and Ned married azshara before he
married Kate so John is legitimate
[Music]
don't forget to enter our December
giveaway subscribe comment and leave a
like hey guys in this video I'm going to
introduce you a theory in which Justin
is a legitimate son of Ned Stark and
ashara dayne before I do so keep in mind
that in order for this theory to happen
it would require the show to pull out
the biggest twist Vivien scene lien and
Rhaegar Targaryen baby would have to
turn out to be someone else and the show
would have to provide a submit back
story guarding the nest arc and a
shardene love story even though there
are only six episodes left one more
twist has been promised us and taking
into account that the Ned Stark plus a
char Dane equals Jon Snow theory holds
quite a bit of clues skins and proof
it's definitely not after the realm of
possibilities to happen lien and Rhaegar
fell in love at the greater need
Harrenhal and according to this tyrion
according to many characters in the book
series they were not the only ones Ned
Stark and char Dane did too and it
resulted with the birth of Jon Snow
ladyasher Dean was a lady of house Dane
and the sister of Surak Dane the sword
of the morning she was stolen had long
hair and violet eyes a sheriff was an
object of infatuation for many men
including Sir Barton sell me and it's
dark Ned Stark meta shared great tourney
at Harrenhal where they shared the last
dance of the celebration and many
characters seem to believe those two
fell in love according to server sell me
one of the stars buried her at the
tournament and gut her with a child
before I continue let me just remind you
that during this journey Ned Stark was
not pledged to anyone it was his older
brother Brandon that was betrothal
Catelyn Tully so he did not break any
vow
according to the entire day in family a
char Ned Stark truly did fall in love at
Harrenhal lady Illyria Danish our
younger sister believes this Lord Eric
Dane also known as Ned the current Lord
of star fuller Cheryl Larry and starters
nephew also believe this in a Storm of
Swords he tells Arya about his family
about how his aunt azshara committed
suicide of her broken heart he the
hesitantly tells Arya that his aunt
hilarya told him that a shard Dennard
fell in lava the greater need here ho
educate surprised that Eddard Stark
never spoke of her so she our sister and
nephew believed that she Ned fell in
love with attorney sadly then the
rebellion broke and had suddenly found
himself to be the new Lord of Winterfell
during the time of war following the
showdown at the Tower of joy Eddard
Stark shell to star fall to inform house
Dane abstractors death and return his
sword Don asure committed suicide by
throwing herself from the top of the
tallest average star fallen to the cliff
a table see it was also known by many
that she was pregnant before she killed
herself a shirt was suspected to be the
matter of just
and that her suicide was caused by the
grief over the hand her alleged lover a
dirt played in her brother's death in
the books Catelyn Stark even asked if
this rumor was true and that our dang
girl told her to never ask him about
John the dubov asked his blood and this
was all she needed
no quoting Ned would not speak of the
matter not so much as a word but a
castle has no secrets and Kathy Harris
remains repeating tales they heard from
the lips of her husband soldiers they
whispered of sir are they in the sword
of the morning dead list of the seven
nights of Aerys Kingsguard and how their
young Lord had slain him in single
combat and they told how afterward Ned
had carried Sir Arthur sword back to the
beautiful young sister who aided him in
a castle called star phone the shores of
the summer sea the lady assured they in
tall and fair with haunting violet eyes
it had taken her a fortnight to marshal
her courage but finally in bed one night
Kathleen as her husband the truth of it
asked him to his face that was the only
time in other years that Ned had ever
frightened her never ask me about John
he said cold as ice he's my blood and
that is all you need to know and now I
will learn very heard that name milady
she had pledged to obey she told him and
from that day on the whispering had
stopped and the charr Dean's name was
never heard in Winterfell again and it
basically shuts her down asks where she
heard the chars name and ensures that
assured Dean's name was never heard in
Winterfell again as already said after
the tourney at Harrenhal the two Heron
see each other up until mr. croto star
fault delivered on to our sister ashara
dayne
however Ned in this theory then found
out that their whole story resulted the
child but both of them knew they could
not be together
by the time Ned saw her again he was
married and had killed her brother all
of this combined sealed an end to their
relationship leading Ashur to commit
suicide over her broken heart again from
arias conversation with Tetrick Dean why
did she jump in the sea though she asked
her heart was broken
edgy cancered did someone break it or
asked he hesitated perhaps it's not my
place tell me or insisted he looked at
her comfortably and said my aunt
hilarious says Lady of Charon dear
father fell in love at Harrenhal let's
now take a look on how other characters
beside the danes saw the relationship
between azshara and Ned Stark here's a
conversation between Cersei Lannister
and Ned how dare you play the noble Lord
with me what are you taking for you're a
bastard than your own I've seen him what
was the matter I wonder some Dornish
peasant arrival her whole face burned
horror or was it a grieving sister Lady
azshara she threw herself into the sea I
am told why was that for
burglary slurred a childhood stole
Cersei Lannister Twitter Stark
let's disturb our stance take on events
at the tourney in a dance of dragons
serve arson Salman remembers the great
tourney at Harrenhal quoting she died
never knowing that sir bar stand had
loved her how could she he was a knight
of the Kingsguard sworn to celibacy no
good could have come from telling her
his feelings no good came from silence
Eder if I had a horse Rhaegar and Crown
to share a queen of love and beauty my
shield look to me instead of Stark
barson says she was a standard by a
start but his version is biased due to
the feelings he had for her but Harvin
gives us more neutral take when talking
to Arya Harvin's a member of the
household guard of Lord Eddard Stark at
Winterfell and he did give us a better
insight regarding the relationship
between ed in the shower ladyish our
Dean it's an old tale that one I heard
he wants at Winterfell when I was older
than you are now I doubt there's any
truth to it but if there is what of it
when Ed met his Dornish lady assure his
brother Brandon was still alive and it
was him betrothed to lady Catelyn so
there's no stain on your father's honour
there's not like a tourney to make the
blood run hot so maybe some words are
whispered in a tent of a knight who can
say words or kisses maybe more but first
harming that spring had come or so they
thought and neither one of them was
pledged carving to Arya Stark now let's
take a look at an evidence that might be
supporting part of the theory that
claims that Ned and azshara were married
we only seen it live when we know he's
lying and we know the exact nature of
the line for example it happens right
before he was killed he lies about
committing treason and once more
sacrifices his honor for the good of his
family what he says is important so
let's take a look at the team let the
High Septon and Baelor the Blessed bear
witness to what I say Joffrey Baratheon
is the one true heir to the Iron Throne
let the High Septon and the seven bear
witness to the truth I say States Ned
the point here is that Ned's first the
seventh at this live was true he doesn't
swear on the old gods the gods he
worships there's actually one other oath
that Ned took to the seven his marriage
vows to Catelyn Eddard Stark married
Kathleen in the fate of the seven-step
wedding one would think that the Lord of
Winterfell would Wed in the gods who the
Winterfell before the weirwood heart
tree but he didn't and the answer might
be lying in a theory that he'd already
married before the old gods when he
married her shardene serve our sasame
stays the char turn to stark and more
importantly he stays a sharp was
dishonored by stark at Harrenhal let's
also take into account the fact that Rob
also did firstly bad and then
immediately after wet ELISA and we've
been told numerous times the trouble is
his father's son could this be a hint
that Ned might have slept with a char at
Harrenhal and then immediately
afterwards fed her it's definitely not
out of the realm of possibilities
for all of you wondering why would not
even Mary Kathleen if he had already
married and loved the shara here's the
answer
during the Robert's rebellion trebles
rubber brother Ned Stark in January
needed to secure the Tully allegiance
and Lord hoster Tully insisted on
marrying his daughters to Ned and John
net hos in this story already strictly
marital Shara had to agree to marry
Kathleen to secure the allegiance and to
win the war there might be one more hint
supporting this theory is Jon's
exceptional skill at arms if John truly
is Ned in the shower son then it makes
her our turday in John's uncle which
might be an explanation why John is such
a skilled warrior the show has made a
huge deal regarding the Danes assessed
role sword on which many suspect to be
the light bringer the jungle will to
defeat the night king however the only
way for the show to bring the sword back
into play would be with this same theory
if John is a sure son then he would have
the right to hold the sword of the
morning title this title is bestowed
upon the knight of house Dane who willed
their family's ancestral sword it's not
hereditary automatically as down to the
current head of house Dane rather the
sword dawn is only held by a member of
House Dane who is considered worthy of
the honor after displaying immense skill
at swordsmanship with John Austin is now
let's see if George are mourned the
creator of this fictional universe
author of epic fantasy novels the Song
of Ice and Fire which was later adapted
in the d HBO series Game of Thrones give
us any clue regarding this theory the
Danes are still going to play an
important role in the future George are
mourn stated this leads us to another
George
Martin's confirmation regarding the
Danes you'll see more Danes in the
future books that's all I can say this
could either mean that we will learn
more the Danes that are already
introduced in a story or we will see
some new characters could it be that
they're Danes that will already know of
but are not aware of them being Danes
let's also point out a fact that george
RR martin confirmed himself george has
worked out the whole family tree for
housing and it will be published in the
future books
this means that something huge is coming
as only the Great Houses get family tree
struct out a fact that george RR martin
is waiting for the right time to publish
this one means that there will likely be
a huge twist regarding the in family
could Ned Stark and John be placed in
his family tree we know that ash are
dense the net we know that she was a
server stand calls a dishonored by a
stark at her home and we know that the
char gave a birth to a child but could
that shall be Jon Snow and as always I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]